salut romain ça bof j'irai diarrhée à la
tête
non non ça c'est plutôt oui bon et sinon
j'ai de l'eczéma à passer dans la tête
aussi
ah non là c'est sûrement oui je vais
hockey et donc je suis un peu stressé
voilà on a longtemps imaginé le corps et
l'esprit comme deux choses complètement
distinctes pourtant les sportifs savent
ça mieux que tout le monde
le mental et le physique ça marche
ensemble où ça marche pas au coeur de
cette histoire il ya un organe
mystérieux quasi mystique le cerveau
c'est cet endroit où se mélangent nos
émotions nos pensées nos humeurs mais
aussi celui qui commande notre système
nerveux donc notre corps du coup quand
on sait ça on se doute bien qu'il ya des
chances pour que les deux aspects soient
levées et vous savez quoi
et oui en réalité imaginer une
distinction totale entre le corps et
l'esprit
ça n'a aucun sens parce qu'on est des
créatures complexe on a plusieurs
dimensions
la dimension biologique c'est à dire
notre corps la dimension psychologique
c'est à dire notre esprit est celle de
notre environnement nos relations aux
autres etc
c'est à dire la dimension sociale et les
trois sont intimement liés donc notre
santé elle dépend pas uniquement de
facteurs biologiques les éléments de
notre vie sociale
ils ont des conséquences sur notre
psychisme qui lui-même influent sur
notre corps et réciproquement et vice et
versa et tutti quanti
j'avoue c'est un peu abstrait bon
imaginons un événement nul dans votre
vie sociale une rupture vous perdez
votre job un de vos proches meneur vous
ne souhaite pas c'est juste pour
l'exemple
ce genre d'événement ça a forcément des
répercussions sur votre moral donc sur
votre psychisme
alors imaginons maintenant que suite à
ça vous fassiez une dépression attention
la dépression c'est pas juste être en
mode
ray maladie la dépression en plus des
manifestations psychologique et social
elle a aussi des conséquences physiques
et par plusieurs mécanismes différents
d'abord la dépression elle provoque des
troubles de plusieurs grandes fonctions
comme le sommeil ou l'appétit par
exemple et ça ça a déjà des
répercussions sur votre corps
la fatigue l'amaigrissement les carences
alimentaires du coup on est plus
sensible aux maladies
et effectivement les personnes
dépressives sont plus malades que les
autres et la dépression à provoque aussi
des douleurs physiques dans les membres
dans les articulations
au niveau de la tête au niveau du ventre
etc plusieurs études ont été menées sur
le sujet et en observant le cerveau des
personnes dépressives grâce à une irm
les différentes équipes ont constaté
plusieurs choses d'abord que les
différents réseaux responsable de la
douleur était effectivement active et
donc la douleur elle était bien réel et
que ce n'est pas une vue de l'esprit
ensuite que chez les patients souffrant
de dépression ces réseaux réagissent
plus fortement que chez les autres donc
notre état psychologique peut déclencher
des douleurs et les amplifier mais il
peut aussi provoquer ou au moins
déclencher certaines maladies on appelle
ça les maladies psychosomatiques
mais attention contrairement à ce que
beaucoup de gens pensent
psychosomatiques ça veut pas dire c'est
dans ta tête c'est pas vrai ça veut
juste dire que c'est un problème
organique donc physiques causées par le
psychisme et ça mérite d'être soignés
comme n'importe quelle maladie
en plus des douleurs chroniques dont on
a déjà parlé les facteurs psychologiques
comme les émotions fortes ou le stress
ça peut déclencher des crises d'asthme
des maladies peau comme le psoriasis ou
l'eczéma des ulcères à l'estomac etc
et si on prend le cas des pathologies
cardiovasculaires évidemment le stress
et bal seul en cause
mais il fait partie des facteurs qui
augmentent votre risque de développer
une maladie mais aussi de déclencher une
crise genre la fameuse crise cardiaque
si vous voulez faire votre part en
soirée on dit l'infarctus du myocarde
cadeaux essayons d'être encore plus
concrète on peut même transformer son
corps de façon visible et immédiate par
la seule force de son esprit savez quoi
faire une expérience
fermez les yeux désormais visualiser une
forme une forme humaine
c'est un corps un corps désirable qui
s'approche du vôtre jusqu'à le frôle il
l'effleuré du sang afflue actuellement
dans vos corps caverneux votre corps est
en train de se transformer en vrai c'est
pas juste une blague vos images mentales
elle provoque des émotions qui
provoquent elles mêmes des réactions
physiques qui ont elles mêmes des
répercussions sur vos organes bon mais
comment ça marche en vrai papa le coût
du sang qui arrivent dans votre comment
ce à quoi vous pensez peut avoir une
influence sur votre corps
d'une certaine manière on en a déjà
parlé dans la vidéo pourquoi le stress
donne la diarrhée on est pile dans le
thème pour comprendre ce qui se passe en
gros faut savoir un ou deux trucs sur
notre système nerveux
déjà pour résumer on en a pas un on en a
deux celui qui nous sert à avoir des
sensations genre le chaud le froid la
douleur etc mais aussi à faire des
mouvements genre marcher ou faire les
gestes qu'on il ya celui qui est sur
pilote automatique on appelle le système
nerveux autonome et qui gèrent nos
grandes fonctions vitales genre la
respiration les battements de notre
coeur et notre digestion et c'est
celui-là qui nous intéresse en gros il a
le pouvoir d'accélérer ou de ralentir
l'activité de nos organes vitaux mais
aussi de changer la taille de nos
bronches ou de nos vaisseaux sanguins et
tout ça ça a des conséquences comme
faire monter ou baisser notre tension
déclencher la sécrétion de certaines
substances nous donner la durée
voilà bon mais pourquoi il fait ça
notre système nerveux autonome pourquoi
il fait le mariole comme ça bah
globalement il rageait des signaux
d'alerté indique qu'il ya quelque chose
qui va pas et qui sont transmis par
notre cerveau et parmi ces signaux pour
garder le même exemple un bon coup de
stress ça peut être perçu par notre
cerveau comme une menace immédiate pour
notre survie notre charge du coup le
cerveau bas il transmet l'info et le
corps se met en mode commando pour être
prêt soit à fuir soit à combattre et
tout ça si c'est répété ça peut avoir
des conséquences durables sur nos
organes et donc sur notre santé ou alors
j'avoue prononcez pas ouf on a un peu
l'impression que notre esprit c'est
l'ennemi de notre corps mais en fait non
d'abord parce que oui être mal dans sa
tête ça a des conséquences négatives sur
le corps mais du coup à l inverse est
bien dans sa tête ça a des conséquences
positives
ne serait-ce que ne pas avoir de
conséquences négatives puis à les
endorphines par exemple les hormones du
plaisir du bonheur du bien-être vous
trouverez plein de mots pour les décrire
elles sont libérées dans différentes
circonstances mais notamment quand vous
vous faites plaisir quand vous faites du
bien de différentes façons
elles ont en effet à la fois apaisant et
au fort is an et cal même les douleurs
tient la douleur d'ailleurs voilà un
truc physique qu'on peut contrôler avec
son esprit tout simplement parce que
c'est pas une sensation purement
physique
c'est un processus complexe qui est
contrôlé par différentes zones du
cerveau et qu'on peut désactiver
certaines de ces zones par différents
moyens en faisant diversion par exemple
c'est à dire en se concentrant sur une
activité mentale
jean compter et si on veut aller encore
plus loin
on veut y aller si on veut aller encore
plus loin on peut parler de ces couples
âgés qui meurent à quelques jours voire
à quelques heures d'intervalle ou des
malades en fin de vie qui attendent la
visite d'un proche qui vient de très
loin et qui décède quelques heures après
les avoir vus là on est dans l'exemple
ultime du pouvoir de l'esprit sur le
corps celui de se maintenir en vie ou
passer de l'autre côté
dans tous les cas et pour toutes les
raisons qu'on vient de voir on peut se
mettre d'accord sur un truc c'est pas
parce que c'est dans la tête qu'il faut
rien faire quand un trouble semble
psychosomatique
d'abord il faut soigner les signes
physiques pour qu'ils soient moins
douloureux et manger nan mais il faut
aussi soigner la cause donc la
souffrance psychologique
georges chez un psy reminder aller chez
un psy ça veut pas dire qu'on est dingue
et quand bien même quand on a mal aux
dents on va chez le dentiste avant que
ça pourrisse et ben c'est pareil avec
les troubles psychologiques et les psys
et puis même sans parler de maladie
globalement vivre heureux c'est toujours
mieux
voilà dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on
se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo
d'ici là plus que jamais et maintenant
vous savez pourquoi
mettez vous bien et du coup portez vous
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]